will californians ever replace the
senator with the plastic face
yeah she's not quite six feet
underground yet insists on sticking
around but should voters be hostile to
another term for this fossile
all right nancy pelosi answered the
question everyone has been asking other
than when will she fight highlander
this week the eyebrow monster announced
she's running for reelection
but look if that rock that killed the
dinosaurs didn't get her then neither
will the 2022 midterms
she first went to congress in 1987 the
year i was born
and has been the top dem in the house
since 2003. nancy made the announcement
on twitter with technical help from
someone one eighth her age and ask
herself what are the three most
important issues facing congress when
people ask me what are the three most
important issues facing the congress i
always say the same thing our children
our children our children
our children our children our children
the last time i heard that it was from a
parent filing a police report outside
cnn
but when she's in the arena does she
take a punch or throw a punch for the
children
as you hear me say
when you're in the arena you have to be
able to take a punch
or throw a punch
for the children ah with all those
punches no wonder shelby sounds like she
has a concussion
but is this election crucial is nothing
less at stake than our democracy this
election is crucial nothing less is at
stake than our democracy
but as we say we don't agonize we
organize and that is why i am running
for re-election to congress that's what
i say but what is this obsession with
children and why won't you just call it
quits
when i first announced i'd be running
for congress i raised a lot of eyebrows
specifically my own four inches above my
face
what keeps me coming back like a looter
to his favorite walgreens
the children
i'm going to keep serving the children
even as their parents pack up a u-haul
and move
out of state
all right that was uh that was uh
that's classic
i don't know who was playing her
[Laughter]
so kat uh yeah what would you tell nancy
well done by the way thank you it hurts
my face to do that no but it was worth
it i got enjoy it you're suffering if
you're suffering makes me smile
it's worth it no i know um
yeah look i get that once you've been
rich and powerful it's probably really
hard i guess to go back to just being
rich
what's the point of like you know using
your power to enrich yourself if you
never take any time to just chill out
and enjoy the spoils of your little scam
exactly
exactly it's like come on why are you
still there emily shouldn't it be not
children children children it should be
feces feces species because that's all
you see she's showing san francisco
that's all it is it's poop poop poop
it's true if that was really the four
sisters behind her and not just a green
screen then she would have gotten hit in
the side of the head
halfway through what she was saying
you're absolutely right and that cr what
character is it with the teeth are like
filed into points that's what i just
keep thinking about here like children
children you know what i'm talking about
rural doll like one of his characters
maybe anyway she also went on to say
that there was an assault on democracy
in the way of three things she said an
assault on the truth the assault on the
capital and an assault on voting rights
so she tells you right now what the
playbook is for the democrat party in
terms of narrative going into the
midterms and going into 2024 and we just
have to keep remembering that that load
is exactly why there's going to be a red
wave takeover no it's true none of those
things are priorities for the people
that are suffering from crime or or
human poop joe i love it every the the
it's mean to the playbook it's always
about the children that's been going on
for like 30 years it started i think in
the 80s it's like it
they never helped the children nothing
they do actually ever helps kids we're
seeing that with a pandemic yeah well
she wants the children for the sweet
sweet stem cells in their blood
to help rejuvenate her
uh yeah it's
we've got to get rid of these
old people they've accumulated too much
power i understand the older folks no
offense
for wisdom your life experience to share
this but i can't think of the job where
someone would say get me an 81 year old
yeah that's who we need in here so they
got to get her out of there and emily
you make excellent point there that
they're set they talk about we've got to
respect democracy but they're already
sowing the seeds there of if we don't
win
everything is a fraud and that is not
democracy democracy you have to accept
the results of a fair election so let's
have fair elections but don't play this
game of if you win everything's great
and if you don't the system's broken it
needs to be overturned yeah tyrus she
doesn't want it's you know it's what cat
originally said it's not just about
wealth she can't let go of the perks
that come with the power of being in a
powerful place okay i'm actually ashamed
of all of you that anyone would be
surprised that she's running again don't
you know that every senator or their
congressman stays till they die that's
the rule you get to die on the chair and
you still get you record your votes
after depending on how rick and mortal
sets it on your fingers and which way
you vote but the fact that she's still
bringing up children yeah even after the
hansel and gretel incident you know i'm
saying like
you know when she was when she
originally ran she promised a
gingerbread house with candy and yeah
you know and the whole kids in the oven
thing but apparently you know enough
time has passed to where now she can
talk about the children again so i would
imagine you're going to see a lot of
investments in candy and stocks from
from her not that she was the insider
trading or whatever so and uh missing
children in the neighborhoods
so be careful all righty coming up who
will the president support for a seat on
the court
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else